cette situation inédite c'est lié à
l'épidémie contraint également les
commerçants à s'adapter en première
ligne elle les employés des commerces
alimentaires les précisions de grégoire
doucet les magasins de proximité
essentiel continue de tourner à plein
régime
après la ruée du début de confinement
les petits commerces principalement
alimentaires s'organise et reste
mobilisée matériel de protection mesures
barrières horaires réaménagés
les enseignes de centre de faire le
nécessaire pour réduire les risques de
contamination en alléguant en a des
masses
on a une séparation entre nous et les
clients on a des lingettes pour
désinfecter toutes les 15 minutes les
caisses nettoyer le matériel que
j'utilise les clients donc c'est un peu
rassurant après il y aura peut-être y
aura toujours au pardon une petite
inquiétude comptant bien travailler
parce qu'on sait pas quelle personne est
porteur du virus
d'autant plus que la personne peut être
porteurs et porteuses et sans symptômes
on ferme à 19 heures donc on
ceux de l'après midi comme moi on vient
appuyer plus tôt à 13 heures vu qu'on
ferme à 19h et même ça des fois on a des
clients des retardataires qui viennent
si de la voix de l'est s'il n'est pas
temps bien les marchands appellent leurs
clients à limiter au strict nécessaire
leur venue au supermarché une règle
respectée avec parcimonie
je sors à peu près une fois par jour
deux fois par jour bon comme je pas
accumulé trop de choses parce que je
fais les courses au jour le jour je
passais pas très longtemps dehors
certains commerçants s'agace de ce
manque de civisme
on peut pas non plus faire la police à
tous nos clients malheureusement il
faudrait les français sont des enfants
gâtés mais c'est un peu le cas c'est le
cas c'est interdire d'interdire
maintenant mais malheureusement il faut
se raisonner et faut que chacun fasse un
peu la police chez soi d'autres
consommateurs sont reconnaissants envers
ceux qui permettent d'assurer le
fonctionnement de la distribution
alimentaire
heureusement que les alimentations sont
ouvertes
parce que mon rentable que personne
seule je travaille en télétravail en
confinement toute la semaine et ça me
fait sortir mais pas très loin autour de
la maison puisse armer un sentiment
social de voir même si on côtoie pas en
respecter les la distanciation
ça permet de voir des gens de voir des
humains
à l'orée du confinement le gouvernement
s'était voulu rassurant sur les risques
de pénurie et continue d'appeler les
français à être responsables dans leurs
achats